no this isn't some alien plant species
though it may look pretty strange this
is actually a team of robots working
together to build a structure by winding
fibers into tubes step one the winding
arm pulls fiber and resin from a tank on
the ground mixes the material in the
nozzle and winds the wetted fiber around
itself step two the robot turns on an
ultraviolet light to cook and harden the
fiber step three using a tiny motor and
wheels the robot inches itself up on top
of the hardened fiber then the process
begins again the robot can change
directions by angling itself at the top
of the recently printed section and it
can use different winding patterns to
change the strength of the build the
swarming BOTS are also able to
communicate with each other through a
computer network this allows them to
avoid running into each other or other
obstacles that might be in their path
together the team of robots can find the
most efficient way to build a structure
researchers think this technology could
be used to build installations in remote
or dangerous environments like after an
extreme weather event they might look a
little strange but these fiber bots are
a well choreographed construction crew